I'll give you the scenario for this
particular person when I first met this
person
he was
with somebody
at a radio event and I was like oh
that's that's weird
and then before we left I saw him making
out with
another famous girl both of these one
was an actress one was a singer and I
was like oh that is
that is so gross
and then what happens then you know much
later on we wind up on a handful of gigs
together
and I get sucked in aren't you disgusted
with yourself when you say I know this
guy's bad for me yes yes yes
and the answer is like drugs you
couldn't help yourself this guy was a
drug this guy was a drug to you I'm
gonna put John Mayer here and I'm gonna
say you love who you love who you love
there you go